I will ask you one more time does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
Harvard's rules of bullying and
harassment here is Elise stefanic asking
Harvard president Claudine
gay the same question and Dr Gay at
Harvard does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of Bing and
harassment yes or no it can be depending
on the context what's the context
targeted as an individual targeted as at
an individual it's targeted at Jewish
students Jewish individuals do you
understand your testimony is
dehumanizing them do you understand that
dehumanization is part of
anti-Semitism I will ask you one more
time does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or no anti-semitic
rhetoric when and is it anti-semitic
rhetoric anti-semitic rhetoric when it
crosses into conduct it amounts to
bullying harassment
intimidation that is actionable conduct
and we do take action so the answer is
yes that calling for the genocide of
Jews violates Harvard code of conduct
[Music]
correct again it depends on the context
it does not depend on the context the
answer is yes and this is why you should
resign these are unacceptable answers
across the board this is so
extraordinary I want to I just want to
make the distinction again she's not
talking about what the first amendment
allows what these people when they call
for the Gen genocide of the Jews or when
they're calling for River to the sea or
any of those things they're trying to
intentionally get as close as they
possibly can to a violation of the First
Amendment right like they're using our
rules against us that's one thing but
that's not what stefanic is asking about
here she's saying what are the policies
of the school you guys when kids come to
the school you get a booklet or a pamp
or something and it's a bullying and
harassment pamphlet try to imagine it
this way try to imagine it this way
imagine if there was a whole bunch of
white kids rampaging through Harvard
calling for the genocide of black people
what do you think Harvard would be doing
right now Connor you're white give me
give me something on this one they would
not allow it according to White
Connor they wouldn't allow it and we all
know they wouldn't allow it and they
shouldn't allow it they have their
policy related to bullying arrestment
the fact that this dingbat Miss gay Dr
Gay which is like just so perfect for
related to all Dr Gay um but the fact
that Dr Gay is like well you know really
it's again when it turns into conduct
okay so when we have 10 dead Jews
hanging in Harvard Square would that be
enough for you would that be a problem
anyway thankfully everyone with their
head on straight and there still are a
couple people uh are calling this out
for the abject lunacy that it is here's
Elon Musk who know is not an anti-semite
let me help them out here calling for
the genocide death of anyone obviously
constitutes harassment again this is
their own policies related to bullying
and harassing right so this is separate
from the First Amendment itself so once
again Elon Musk just doing the right
thing the thing that we all know but
that these corrupt mind muddled social
justice freaks who have been given you
know jobs that these people are probably
paid 300 or $400,000 a year to do um
it's just
disgusting